hi there steve kaufman i'm going to talk
to you about
six hacks for mastering chinese
basically based on my experience when 40
odd years ago
within a nine-month period i went from
scratch to where i could read novels
translate diplomatic documents in
chinese both english and the chinese
chinese into english
hack number one the first month or maybe
to focus on
listening and opinion
is the romanization
just get used to the sounds it's too
difficult in my view to start learning
characters when you don't even have
words it's easier to learn things when
you have something meaningful that you
can refer it to so
you listen to stuff you read the opinion
and by this time you're getting more and
more keen to attack the characters
the characters for the words that you
have now already learned so hack number
one is focus on pinyin for the first
month or two
second thing is once you decide to just
to study characters
this is the second hack go at them
full time full-time meaning half an hour
a day at least and develop your own
memory system you may use anki
i had a system where i use these flash
cards these are now well over 40 years
old and i developed my own sort of
uh s you know space repetition system
writing which i can explain to people if
they want but
learn those first thousand characters
thereafter you'll find that you'll be
able to pick them up because so many
elements repeat and and it becomes
easier to learn them through your normal
reading activities but the first
thousand
second hack is make a deliberate effort
almost as a separate activity to learn
those characters that's hack number two
hack number three is
focus on patterns if you are uh whatever
your um
book is that you're using don't get
caught up in complicated grammar
explanations focus on patterns uh when i
was studying we had a wonderful book
by harriet mills and p.s knee was called
intermediate reader in modern chinese a
pattern approach every single lesson
they introduced patterns and
to me that's how i
sort of got a sense of how the language
worked and developed these patterns
which became almost like the frames
around which i could build
my whatever i wanted to say
so uh focus on patterns that's number
three
number four
read a lot
read a lot
and um
when i in my case and and find
interesting things that you want to read
in my case very soon after we um
got past our initial
sound only pinyin only
uh text called chinese dialogues we
graduated to a thing called 20 lectures
on chinese culture 20 lectures on
chinese culture is very interesting
history it consists only of text and a
glossary
no complicated explanations no
no
no
you know quizzes
and and when i look at this and this was
a sort of a lower intermediate book 20
lectures in chinese culture and today i
when i was in china the last time i
bought this you know gauging how you
call you it's advanced spoken chinese
okay it's full of the most
boring
content about so-and-so went to school
and met his friend and they went to the
barber and they went skating and i don't
know what and it's full of questions and
stuff like that and there's only one
thing to do with this kind of book in my
opinion throw it away
i don't like it
unless you're interested in that kind of
stuff so and so when skating
uh
i graduated from 20 lectures in chinese
culture to this reader
in modern chinese which was fascinating
and introduced the patterns and then i
went on to
you know novels like lotus youngza so
read read a lot much easier to do today
because the internet provides so much
content you can use online dictionaries
you can study at link so
read
next
focus on
listening to things that you like in my
case i listened to a lot of xiangsha
but nowadays you can get online you can
go to beijing and buy you can buy
elsewhere cds of the classics of chinese
of history novels you name it loto sions
is available if you look at my latest
blog post you'll see a link to a site
where you can download an audio version
free of charge so
focus on sounds so and one last hack
that flows from this uh focusing on
sounds and this is something i'm going
to admit i have tended not to be a great
fan of shadowing because i didn't
really do it but i'm saying to myself
chinese with this intonation with the
music of the language i think
you should shadow and i must admit i'm
gonna try doing more shadowing now with
my korean
and even though while you're trying to
speak while you're listening you miss
stuff and you don't understand it as
well and it can affect
trying to really enjoy the content so i
wouldn't suggest you do it all the time
but as a process of getting used to the
music
of the language
give it a try let me know how it works
it may be that plus a lot of listening
to
you know real lively chinese that you
like is going to help your brain get
used to the tones
uh a better solution than trying to
memorize
the tone for each word so there you have
it uh those are my six
hacks on learning chinese bye for now